Wonderful.
Josh Becker, thank you for joining me
on 20 Minute Leaders.
How are you?
I'm very good.
Thank you for having me.
Thank you for taking the time to do this.
I know you just got back
from a long trip.
So I really appreciate it
and I know how busy you are.
Brief background
and then I'm gonna ask so many questions
because I know so little about the things
that you do.
The scope of the things that you do
but they're so fascinating.
So Stanford Business School,
but also a law degree from Stanford.
Always thinking about
public interest entrepreneurship.
What does that even mean?
I can sense by the name,
but I don't really know.
The Full Circle Fund,
helping non-profits.
I think you've deployed over
a 100,000 hours of help
through that. Incredible.
And you're running
for state Senate this year,
which I also I'm excited to learn about
what that transformation is like
and what it means to innovate
within government.
Okay, let's take a break now.
Josh, tell me who you are, please.
Well, thanks. Yeah, this is really fun.
I really appreciate you having me.
Yeah and thinking about it
I mean, there are things
that run through all of that.
And for me, it really is innovation.
I love innovation in any respect.
So, whether in the private sector,
in the nonprofit sector,
or now
in the government sector.
And for me there's really been a theme.
I actually started out more
on a public policy basis.
I mean out of undergrad,
I was really focused on environment.
Environmental activism.
Went to DC.
Worked in policy.
Worked at some campaigns.
And it was almost a fluke, really,
that I ended up in business school.
But in the in-between time,
I applied and I came out,
I got involved with a guy named
Jack Hidary starting
early Internet company called Earth Web.
And this was 1994, early days of the web.
Bringing a physical computer over
to the Metropolitan Museum of Art,
showing them the Web saying,
"Hey we'll build a website for you."
And I got really involved.
By the time
I came out to Stanford in 1995.
It's like, wow, this is really
a great place to be.
And so, I got really into innovation
in the private sector
in the early Internet days
and ultimately in clean tech.
And it became to see a way to really meld
my common interests
in the public good with innovation.
And I did it both in what
we call impact investing
and this was the really early days.
We started a fund in
the impact investing space
which actually is now growing.
And we're focusing on businesses
that had a real social impact.
So, clean energy was one of them.
Wow. But that's pretty, you know, I go to quite a few
of the classes at the business school
and a lot of my friends
are at the Stanford Business School.
It's pretty rare that somebody
comes in there and goes out of there
with the sense of responsibility of
devoting most of their time
to doing social good.
I mean, there is a trend
and a lot of people are saying,
"Yes, I want my business
to do social good."
But you're saying
it's about the social good.
It's not about necessarily
just the business.
The social good is the motivation.
It's not just a buy.
It's not just,
a by consequence, right?
Yeah, and personally
I see a lot of young students right now
that you are really interested,
as you say, in that intersection
But we were kind of on the early edge of that
and in fact we had our own conference we created
called the Zero Trade-Off
Investment Conference.
And we look at things that could actually
create a great financial return
and a great social return.
Right.
But clean energy was one of those.
And we got involved
in a company called Opower
that was really about using
social psychology to get people
to reduce their energy use.
And that ended up being a huge success.
And again, showed me what's possible.
Inner city, we've had a focus
on inner city and ethnic entrepreneurs.
So, I'm still on the board of a company
that's now called UR Welcome.
UR Welcome, with U and a R.
And it's kind of like USAA for immigrants.
And then we had inner city
something called the Villa,
which was an inner city shoe store
really got ...
parents' sneaker store
and started opening up the inner city
and building work skills and life skills.
And so a number of those things.
And then Full Circle Fund,
I realized so many of my friends
from business school and law school
that did have a really deep interest
in doing good in the world,
but they were busy.
Everyone's you know,
you're busy with your lives,
your work, your kids.
And so, we said,
"Let's pool together
our time and our money."
And that was Full Circle Fund
and we started that actually
this is almost exactly 20 years ago.
This our 20th anniversary year.
Wow.
And it's just that way I found,
like you see some books behind me,
I find when I'm part of a book club,
I read more books.
So, when I'm part of something like
Full Circle, I ended up giving more
because you build a social
community around giving.
And it's also, it's available.
So I mean, right now,
a lot of this idea of you wanna get
something done
I love behavioral economics
and when you talk about the social psychology
of reducing energy.
So Dan Ariely is a big mentor of mine.
And one of the things that
I was always inspired by him was he says,
Listen, we're irrational people.
It's really hard to change ourselves,
but if we can change our environment
to fit what we want to achieve,
like joining a book club
and then you're systematically forced
to read a book.
Or joining the Full Circle Fund
and now you have the accessibility
to go and help others.
I think that's marvelous.
Josh, tell me a little bit about this
innovation in government
because I wanna make sure
we leave enough time for this
because I think it's fascinating.
You're running for Senate.
How do you do this transition
from entrepreneur investor to government?
What motivates you to do that?
Sure. I proabably have Dan Ariely's book
right behind me.
Wonderful.
Yeah. I think you look and see where
you can have the biggest impact.
And when I started really focusing
on the state of California and realizing
we have a
two hundred billion dollar budget
If it were our own country, we'd
be the fifth or sixth largest
economy in the world.
And there's really not that
many state senators.
There's 40 state senators.
And probably five to 10 of those 40
who are really probably the most influential.
And then saw, began to see that
as an opportunity for change.
Essentially this is the board of directors
for the state of California,
the United States Senate,
and the state House.
And the more I started to focus on that
... this is a real opportunity.
And listen, I'm sure
and I ... friends up there now, and
it is still 40 in the Senate,
80 in the House,
so it's still 120 people still,
I'm sure it's ... bureaucratic at times.
But when you look at the opportunity
for leverage, I think it's tremendous.
And whether it's meeting
our clean energy goals.
We're, California,
I think it's the hope,
certainly for the US
and one of the big hopes for the world.
And by the way I'm really excited
about collaboration,
as I've done in my past life
about collaborating with Israel
and the amazing technology around water.
Totally.
And around solar, around storage
that's coming out of Israel.
I'm really looking forward
to collaborating there.
So, whether it's clean energy,
whether it was focusing on social justice
and criminal justice reform,
that California was this
huge leverage point.
And I got really excited about that.
And that's what I'm going up there to do.
That's incredible.
So and is this like a spontaneous gut feeling
that you have to do this?
Or is this something that you feel
like you've worked towards for years?
Which of these two?
It's a little bit of both to be honest.
I mean, like I said, I started out in DC
before I came out to Stanford
and business school, law school.
I was already focused on policy.
So it's not like a brand new,
like I woke up one day and decided
I had to do it.
So I'd say it was more of an evolution
in terms of really
I never thought I would personally run.
That's something I never thought
for sure would ever happen.
So, but I was always very interested
in policy
maybe more so
than other kids or other young adults.
So I'd say it's a bit of an evolution.
Right. And I mean,
you're gonna come there.
I don't know how many people
that are Senators have a background,
this entrepreneurial and innovative
background that you have.
Do you think that's gonna be a challenge?
Or is that going to be a fun experience
being sort of the odd one out?
I think it'll be a little bit of both.
I'm sure it'll be some
eye opening situations.
So I think it'll be a little bit of both,
but I am really excited about it.
And hopefully people
will turn to me on certain issues
and look at me whether
I've got some degree of expertise
to bring.
But at the same time,
I need to be humble as well
and realize there's a lot I have to learn
about the state of California,
I'm already starting now,
but it's such a massive state
with its agricultural economy,
the Hollywood economy,
the tech economy.
There's just so much to learn.
Like I said, I just got back from this trip
all the way down the eastern Sierras
all the way to Death Valley.
It's a really incredibly diverse state
so I've got a lot to learn as well.
I think it's unbelievable.
But the perception of young entrepreneurs
like myself when we think of
government, senator, congressmen,
we look back at these funny videos
with Zuckerberg
sitting in front of Congress
and they're asking him,
"Well, so how do ads work?
Are you tracking people
and are you showing them stuff
that they should buy?"
And so our perception,
somebody who sits in the government
is not necessarily the most tech savvy,
not necessarily the best representative
of where innovation takes it.
You're bringing
a different perspective to this.
So, how do you see this mishmash
of both bureaucracy and innovation
and tech and crises that are happening?
I mean, you really have
to balance everything.
Yeah, I think when you look
quick changing government,
and I've also done it in law by the way
I started a whole company. I spent
10 years in legal analytics.
We brought data and analytics to the law.
Which was a long, so that was the long game -
What does that mean
bringing data analytics to the law?
Yeah. In politics sometimes gotta play
the long game, too.
And thinking driving across the state.
I've been on the board
of UC Merced for 15 years.
That was a government decision that said
"Hey we need to start a new UC campus
in the Central Valley"
And first it was a 100 students
and now it'll be 10,000 students.
And my friend Jack's
now at Google X and so we had a
a call now that
Google is getting serious
about diversifying the STEM pipeline.
And we've got all these great diverse
engineering students coming
out of UC Merced.
And so, sometimes you got to,
but it took a long,
it didn't happen overnight.
But it was, people were very
forward thinking to say,
"Hey great. We need a new UC.
Let's put it in the Central Valley.
Let's encourage college attendance"
And so, sometimes you gotta play
the long game in government.
Jack is actually a very good friend
of my father's
and every time I meet him,
my mind is just blown.
The work they're doing there
on quantum computing is just phenomenal.
So, bringing analytics and data to legal.
What does that mean?
What did you try to do there?
Sure. Basically in a nutshell, we realized
it started really around patent,
some area that a lot of entrepreneurs
get very frustrated with the patent system.
And we realized there's just no data.
There's no data about
when you get hit with a patent lawsuit,
who is this person that sued me?
What's their pattern of behavior?
Are they looking for a quick buck
or is this a serious company
that takes things all the way?
And they've got a serious claim here.
There's really, there was no data.
No data about judges.
Who's this judge I'm in front of?
What is their, what is her pattern of behavior?
And so we realized this endemic in law.
There's just no data.
And so we said that data
is actually out there
it's just buried in millions of lawsuits.
So, we said,
"Hey, we can extract out
the millions of data points
from millions of cases"
Then we could tell you
if you're in front of certain judge.
We can say,
"Hey, in the last thousand cases
of this type in front of this judge,
here's the lawyers
that have the most experience
through the years who've won the most motions.
Here's a strategy
you might think about pursuing.
And here's how this judge
has ruled on these kinds of cases"
I mean, I think I kind of blindly assumed
that this is how a lot of these law firms
work today.
That when they're advising on a case,
that they're able to look back at thousands
of other similar cases
because history repeats itself constantly
and be able to give those insights.
You're saying that
that's not really the case?
Well, I know a lot of brilliant lawyers,
but you can't keep 3000 cases in your head.
I mean, it's been the ultimate
anecdata business, right?
It's like, "Oh, yeah, I had this case
in front of this judge.
And I remember this"
I love that, anecdata.
I've never heard that before.
I'm gonna start using that.
... anecdotes it's anecdata.
And that's really what it's been.
It's all reputation based too.
"Oh, this law firm's
got a great reputation"
"I need a great lawyer.
Oh you gotta talk to Lisa"
But really, there's just no data behind it.
I mean, it's like VC too, frankly.
You always put your wins.
If you go to any VC website,
they're gonna say,
"Oh, look at all our great exits."
They don't say,
"Oh, here's the other 100 companies
we invested in that didn't make it" Right?
- 100%
I mean, now with
Now people have gotten a little more data there,
but that was also a data void.
Interesting. And so when was this
that you started this firm?
So, this is actually
it was a public interest project
at Stanford Law.
And what was amazing,
you probably know Andrew Ng.
Of course.
Google day
So, Andrew, when he was
still full time at Stanford
and then Chris Manning,
who runs Natural Language Processing.
Yeah.
The founders of this
public interest project
went to Andrew and Chris and said,
"Will you help us?"
And they first said No
'cause they're very busy.
And then ultimately they said,
"Hey, this is good for the country."
And they got involved
and they got excited about,
specially Chris,
you know natural language processing.
So, I was very fortunate,
this was way before I was involved. This
back in 2006, 2007.
And then it spun off as
a public interest project in late 2010.
They brought me in 2011 to grow it.
So, but it still took nine years.
Now, it's part of LexisNexis and it's growing.
We just passed three million cases
that are now in the system.
We just added a whole new area of law.
We're starting to add states now
because so much of what happens
is at the state level,
and that's even much much harder place
to even get the raw materials
'cause most states
don't even have electronic court records.
So, anyway it's been the long game,
the long journey
but it's really transforming
the way law is practice.
So, you worked on projects
with Jack Hidary.
This project was had involvement
with Andrew Ng and Chris.
I mean, these are just
the top of the top of the top
of the world thinkers.
So I think that's just incredible.
What are you most excited
about moving forward?
And actually right before that,
the election, how does it even work?
What do you have to do?
Because a lot of the times
when people in tech,
they're thinking of politicians
and the elections,
it almost seems like,
"Oh yeah, he asked to go do that.
He has to go talk.
He can't just do"
Talk to me a little bit
about this election process.
Sure. One thing I'll just say,
because a lot of people
who are entrepreneurs come in,
they think they can just waltz in
to the political system,
and it doesn't work that way.
You really have to become
part of the ecosystem.
You have to really get to know
all the players.
And Woody Allen used to say
"98% of life is just showing up"
You really have to show up at all
the local Democratic clubs
and all the local meetings
and really get to know people.
You cannot just waltz in and say,
"Hey, I'm gonna run for this thing."
It's just it's a very different
The world's even here in
Silicon valley are just not connected.
People, in fact it can also be a negative
in some ways.
So you really, so I really put
in many years of hard work
and fund work.
But hard work at the local level
and just getting to know people
and spent 18 months before the primary
just on this race alone.
So, 'cause we have twenty four cities
in my district
and it spans all of Silicon Valley
from South San Francisco
down to Sunnyvale.
And each one has city council members,
each has school board members,
there's county officials and
they're doing hard work for many years.
And you got to understand that.
So, you really have to put in the time
and I'm proud that I did that.
Finished first in the primary.
We have in California a great system,
a top two system.
So, basically the top two
vote getters advance.
And what that means is, usually,
you actually have two Democrats
in this area so people then get
to choose between a flavor of Democrat.
Or in Orange County
you might have two Republicans.
Actually, in my race, I did very well
and there was a lot of other Democrats.
So it ended up being me and a Republican
that we'll be facing off in November.
So we have the top two primaries -
For the whole state?
What'd you say?
That's gonna be for the whole state?
No. This is our district.
So, each state senate district
is about a million people.
So, our district is from everything, basically
everything from the border
of San Francisco down to Sunnyvale.
Okay.
So, I get the Israeli Kibbutz
in Sunnyvale as part of my -
100%. I had a talk with the
mayor of Sunnyvale back then,
Larry, about back in,
what was it?
I think two, three months ago.
And then halfway through the talk,
he mentioned that he's also
a program manager at a startup,
at a battery startup.
And I thought it was just,
it was hilarious that
I'm talking to a mayor of a city.
In Israel, you never have that.
So I think it was just phenomenal.
And what are you most excited about
the next few years, potentially
serving as a senator?
Yeah. I'm very excited about
the opportunity to make change in areas
that we've  talked about.
Clean energy.
Got to lead the world.
Criminal justice reform.
Education.
Higher education.
We need three more
UC Merceds in this state.
More access for kids.
Those are just a few of the areas,
but I'm really excited
about the opportunity to lead
in all those. Build a world class
transportation system here,
especially in the Bay Area.
I just got off a call on that.
So, those are some things I'm
really passionate about.
And now looking at this
crisis that we're facing globally
and you're at the intersection
of both innovation and government,
so, you're getting the flavor of both.
In your take,
where are we headed with this?
And what are the things to be either
optimistic about or pessimistic about?
Well, I think there's
reason to be optimistic
and we've seen even through this pandemic
both how communities have rallied.
I mean, certainly in the US we have some
divisiveness and polarization right now
that we need to get through.
But you've also seen there's a lot
of great stories about
neighbors helping neighbors.
And innovation, whether people
how they're running
their small businesses differently.
How cities are opening
up streets for restaurants or how,
I just got email today.
... looked at a guy,
"Hey, I'm leaving Samsung
to lead this covid-related company."
And was like, "Wow that's really cool."
So I mean there's a lot of people
doing really cool work
and it's gonna
and biotech is also an area
I spend a lot of time on now
especially in oncology.
And to see that we will have a vaccine
and faster than we've ever had one before.
And it's not overnight
as these things are.
But we're getting there
and the innovation piece is critical.
100% Josh, thank you so much
for your time.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you for doing this
right after you're back from your trip.
Before we leave, I have to ask you
for three words that best describe you.
Thank you.
I would say innovative,
thoughtful.
and passionate,
Innovative. Thoughtful. Passionate.
And I think one of the things
that I'm most inspired by
and I'm taking a lesson for myself
is this persistence and consistency
with putting the public interests first.
I think it shines on all the different
endeavors over the past decades.
And the fact that
you're able to do these endeavors
with the greatest thought leaders
in the world.
Seriously, I mean, all the people
that we've talked about, I mean,
they're really just incredible.
And I'm very very excited that people
are now entering the politics space
and government with the insight
and the experience of what it takes
to bring innovation
And thank you very much.
I look forward to seeing you up there.
Thank you. Thanks for having me.
Take care. Bye bye.